[Música]
você tá
filmando os detalhes é isso
agora chega de brincadeira a gente tá
aqui para se divertir mas também tá aqui
para treinar né já se diverte muito já
deu umas voltas já bebemos já fizemos
muita coisa agora
da Saúde ó eu tô indo agora
tem um rapaz que tá aqui que é o filho
do dono da casa que é bom que você é
doido e tal vamos fazer um treino junto
Falei
que não sei quem tal eu digo eu mano que
já apanhei foi para o popô mano então
vou deixar para quando eu voltar tomar o
meu suplemento e ela vende direto para o
consumidor final somente pelo site tá
envia também para todo o Brasil da
fábrica direto para sua casa por isso
que os preços são um pouquinho baixo
13 anos de mercado pode confiar gostoso
agora vamos lá
[Música]
não sabe cuidar de uma chave todo dia
que nós sai não esquece a chave todo dia
é só uma coisa que tem que fazer né
porque que essa porta aqui eletrônicos
e eu tenho uma outra chave reserva na
carteira só que a carteira tá no móvel
lá em cima e é isso ficou lá tchau
[Música]
segunda-feira
começa a full times por dia mas depois
ele vai falar disso com vocês agora mas
a gente já tá treinando já estamos de
férias e treinando
[Música]
Eita
nós podemos treinar de novo
eu fazia na academia na tua outros
esportes Só que os outros esportes são
perigoso Muay Thai
Angels work times Box love
[Música]